(dramatic music)
I've done a lot of videos about Tinder.
If I don't win this category,
it is fuckin' pathetic.
I wasn't gonna go there, but you did.
Next.
(upbeat them music)
So now we're gonna all
set up Tinder profiles.
Oh God.
I've never been on Tinder.
I'm not really a dating apps type person.
Everybody's into it.
You can find someone to bang tonight.
That's the point, right?
Okay, so Zach is an expert of Tinder.
It's better to have photos
where you're looking off camera.
It's really bad to start
with a group photo.
Hot, hot, fun, fun, funny.
I know people are looking for.
Five photos to reel in them babes.
None of the other guys
have ever done this before.
So in theory, Zach should have this.
I am Dr. Jess.
I am the sociologist for Tinder.
And I study online dating
and facial attractiveness.
Hey, Dr. Jess.
Hi, Zach.
So good to see you today.
I guess I'll just hand over my phone now.
So real quick, you swiping left or right?
Number one, you're wearing glasses.
And while you have very nice glasses,
it obstructs your eyes,
which provide us with a very strong signal
of whether or not you're
trustworthy as an individual.
Trustworthy!
Let's move on to the next one.
You're in front of a brick wall.
It's a cool wall.
You're not facing the camera.
Right?
And you're wearing your glasses again.
Well I wear, I need them to see.
Well, you could take them
off for the photograph.
Someone can tell you where to look.
(laughing) Okay, yeah.
I'm gonna go ahead and tell you
that there's glasses in every photo.
Okay.
That's how I see.
So I'm dropping, I'm
dropping the glasses for now.
But I'm here to help.
Well okay.
I know what my best photo is.
It's a picture of me in my Keith shirt
holding fried chicken.
That's a cute boy right there.
- [Dr. Jess] Chicken and biscuits.
Uh-huh.
In a bouquet.
Yes.
You're losing points for
the chicken and waffles.
Why, whoa! (laughing)
Or chicken and biscuits.
Let's dial it back.
You're losing points because I don't know
what this says about you, other than--
What do you mean what does it say,
my shirt has my name on it!
You didn't even talk about that!
So you're worried about being lost
and people not knowing who you are
and that you've got cardiovascular
disease on your mind.
Is that what this conveys?
Yes, exactly.
(laughing) Cardiovascular
disease on my mind?
This says nothing about you.
This says a lot about me.
To the left.
Oh fuck.
I met my wife before
online dating was a thing
so I have absolutely zero
experience making profiles.
I can't see your face.
- [Ned] Aw, come on, I'm kissing the dog.
You can see my eyes--
- [Dr. Jess] I can only
see half your face.
I wanna see the whole face.
We know that by showing your whole face
you're 20% more likely
to be swiped right on.
So I just have to hold the
dog and look into the camera.
That actually sounds
like a pretty good photo.
But this a fun photo.
It shows you in the outdoors.
And you're also wearing formal wear,
which could help signal
that they're more serious
about meeting a romantic partner.
I am serious about meeting
a romantic partner.
So serious that I've already met one.
Here's a photo of me in this really cute
beige outfit against a dumpster.
Do you say thought or is it T-H-O-T?
Yeah, that's my thot.
That hoe over there, yeah.
So, Eugene, what do you think
this photo says about you?
I like standing against dumpsters.
It would be great to know more about you,
not just that you like trash.
I do like trash.
So here you're in a
photograph with three women.
Three drag queens.
I didn't know that these women
were necessarily drag queens.
They're just so good at drag.
Next.
I thought I nailed that one.
Nope.
Are you in Italy or Europe?
I am in Italy or Europe.
So that's a good conversation starter.
People are going to wanna
know more about you,
talk about your trip to Europe.
But I would like to have
a little more back story
about the fact that you were in Florence
at the Palazzo Borghese.
(yelling) What am I
supposed to do, Dr. Jess?
I'm like sleepy, a little bit sleepy.
And I'm in front of a nice background.
I hate this photo
I'm cute as fuck in that photo!
I don't know anything about you.
I'm smiling kindly.
You look like you're up to something.
Up to kindness.
Not necessarily.
Not nonnecessarily.
Well we know that about
ten percent of Tinder users
include dogs in their profile photos.
Do you like cats, Zach?
I love cats.
So what happens if she's a dog owner?
Many people are dog owners.
I have two dogs.
See, this is where this is coming from.
So if you showed me a picture of a dog,
I'd be like, wow she's
a loving animal person.
But all of a sudden, I have cats
and it's the end of the world.
There's an animal double standard
and I will not stand for it.
No more!
You are abusing animals.
The dog looks like it's
being tortured in the bag.
- [Eugene] He's having a great time!
Oh my gosh, I can't breathe, let me out!
He loves being in the bag.
Take him out of the bag.
But he wanted to be in the bag.
He told you this?
And also, you don't own this suit,
so you're stealing.
I'm not, what, I'm not leaving with it.
I'm trying it on!
How do they know that?
Your face is strained to the point
where you look constipated.
Yeah, no I was hulking out, you see.
I just don't think that this
is a really good look for you.
Yeah, well I don't have
any other photos of me
with a giant Lego Incredible Hulk.
This is my head as a cake.
- [Dr. Jess] I hate this.
It's funny.
It's horrifying!
You're not smiling either.
The cake's not smiling.
You would be afraid too if
you got turned into a cake.
Maybe.
I don't know anything about you.
Ooooooh, I disagree there.
- [Dr. Jess] I know nothing about you.
You like pie.
You know one thing.
What do I know?
That I like pie.
- [Dr. Jess] Okay, you're not smiling.
You're not facing forward.
And once again, unhealthy food choices.
Those are not unhealthy.
It's a box.
If it's in a box--
I'm not eating the box!
Okay.
That was Keith's recommendation.
Here's a half naked photo of you.
Yeah he told me I had to do--
I have one in a Speedo.
My mom's a nutritionist.
She says if it's in a box, it's unhealthy.
So, strike.
Does fruit not travel in
boxes to the grocery store?
They put it in crates.
Yeah, that's a box.
It's a different kind of box.
It's a, aha!
Also by wearing clothing,
you're going to attract
a far wider audience.
How about this one?
Oh, this will get all
the girls to swipe right.
A photo of you with your
wife on your wedding day.
This says I am available!
What's the yellow stuff that looks like--
Bell peppers!
The yellow stuff looks like spaghetti.
It's not,
why would I eat spaghetti at the LA Phil?
Even people who don't
necessarily want children
don't wanna witness abuse.
There's a Christmas tree.
You know I'm somewhere.
Actually I hate Christmas too.
So are you trying to tell people
that you like sophisticated music?
Yeah!
I can appreciate that.
We can skip my bio.
We don't have to--
No, bios are critical.
Bios are absolutely critical.
That's what I heard too.
I'll never do you dirt dirt dirt.
It's a Rihanna lyric.
Are you Rihanna?
People love Ri-Ri!
That just shows that I've got taste--
I think that you need so much
work it's not even funny.
(laughs)
It's a little funny.
No.
I like white wine and traveling the world.
Let's split a bottle and
get to know each other.
There are many people who like white wine
and traveling the world.
Luckily, Dr. Jess, your
opinions only matter so much.
I already sent it to my wife
and she says, I would
put the dog photo first.
(Keith laughing in background)
Loves dogs, hates babies.
Should I have written more?
Yes, more and something
that wasn't so off-putting.
Are any of these photos better?
Well you need to smile.
You're not smiling in
hardly any of these photos.
Oh yeah, my mom says that a lot.
See, your mom's a smart lady.
Is this your mom?
No, that's my grandma.
My mom's really pretty.
Your grandma's pretty too.
(Keith laughing in background)
Hey ladies, let's fall in love.
Each day that passes with each of us
remaining alone is one less day of bliss.
Kisses, yo future heart.
(laughing)
You wanna talk about you and
what you're about, Keith.
This bio tells me nothing about you.
What about when I said the word bliss?
That doesn't work for me.
It doesn't work for me.
But are you swiping right on me?
Swiping to the left.
(laughing)
Did Ned win?
I can't tell you who won.
Yeah, I bet.
I can't tell you--
You really hated the other three of us.
I can't tell you who won.
Well we'll just have to keep it a mystery.
I like mystery.
We all like mystery.
I'm very mysterious.
Guys, I think we all had
very fun, cute profiles.
I would swipe right on all of us.
Me too.
There should be an app
just for finding friends
that you can make videos with.
And get naked together.
Yeah.
We'll call it the Try App.
Tryther.
The Trap.
Download our new app, The Trap.
The Trap, where you can find strangers
to get naked with and have fun.
It's a trap.
(ding)